you going to take the booking or no I'm
taking the straps I'm taking the straps
I ain't going out there I'm way out of
bounds I wouldn't want to even touch
grounds right there oh I wouldn't people
on the blog saying that oh he's disy nor
so what I am disy nor and I would never
go up there I'm not stupid and you would
never come down here well I've noticed
like a lot of the a lot of the ogs are
uniting from the south and the north I
don't want to speak on the ogs I don't
speak on Prison politics prisons prisons
the streets is the streets but I talk
about music we're talking music wise
whatever they got going hey I I listen
to that my politics are different I
don't speak on that so what I speak on
though is music wise people say norel
are better than Southside rappers this
is for music they're not they're not
they're hard I don't bump none of this
stuff you know what I'm saying and they
stay dissing the homies so why is
everybody all butur that I'm saying [__]
them cuz they stay dissing us I would
it's a big topic it's everybody saying
Lefty says I I would never do a song
with them I would never go up there and
go to their side of town and I don't
think they would ever come down south